hey everybody and welcome to a
classified wild ride with steo we are
going to the other side baby talking
about aliens and UFOs and my most
important question is why does anybody
care seriously to the Layman like what
does this matter can we talk in terms
that matter and that's what we did and I
think that's why we might have had the
most gripping entertainment palatable
episode that we possibly could have had
with Jeremy corbel what can I say baby
it doesn't get wilder than this ride and
we've got a guest host so strap on and
let's get into it ladies and gentlemen
Jeremy
Corbell yeah dude what's up Ste all
right and special guest oh yeah that's
right we have a special guest co-host Mr
all Oliver tree this is my honor to be
here big time fan Jeremy what's up
Oliver man and you met Scott Randolph
that's right what up um this is a an an
unusual setup but we're talking about
unusual things and um of course you're
uh is it safe to say you're the World's
foremost UFO expert I I certainly hope
not I I sincerely [__] hope not yeah
so uh you know I think that there's a
lot of people that been working on this
issue for a long time uh probably the
least likely candidate to to be you know
kind of so deep into this I didn't think
I'd ever be professionally studying UFOs
or whatever the hell you say um but you
know right tool for the right job people
say I'm a tool so there you go um now
you like you claim yourself to be a
journalist I do that for self-defense
yes okay yeah did did journalism uh
prede the
UFO yeah yeah the the fascination with
this unknown bizarre phenomenon U no not
at all I was a marshal athlete I started
training Jiu-Jitsu when I was a young
kid boxing wrestling all that stuff nice
and I thought that's all I'd ever do for
my whole life you know then you get
injured really bad at some point and you
can't do the same stuff so transition
from that to to Fine Art which was again
total imposter syndrome I can't draw a
stick figure but that started for me I
kind of got into that but the whole time
along I was interested in UFO was like
the nuts and bolts the hardcore physical
craft the idea and then the journalism
thing was I just pestered this guy
[__] over and over his name is George
[__] nap he's a he's a
investigative reporter out of Las Vegas
Nevada and I figured he if anybody knew
what the [__] was up what was true what
was not true good starting point so he
goes to me for like two years then
finally I got through to him and you
know he kind of mentored me now for over
a decade so the the title of journalist
was bestowed upon me by the public so
I'll accept it because it provides me uh
additional coverage in a way I am
reporting the news I am breaking news
but I never thought of myself like that
never studied journalism but I learned
from the best so that's kind of and in
between that I made movies about UFOs
you know was also unexpected like the
Bob Lazar movie right right and so that
kind of thrust me into a position where
people were confiding in me things that
they hadn't told their families hadn't
told their children haven't whispered to
their dogs you know I me it's like right
it's so kind of accidental uh journalist
but the first movies that you made made
it on Netflix yeah [__] insane right
I mean you have three movies on Netflix
right so two on Netflix one on Hulu and
now they're kind of everywhere because I
took them off the platform so look
here's the deal man I figured that I
would just try and so I just made a
movie and to my utter astonishment it
got picked up on Netflix and went wild
and that was before the Lazar film it's
called patient 17 yeah so I figured well
is that
easy know keep it up I think I got real
lucky and hopefully I made good films
yeah how long did that take you to make
the the first movie you know it's funny
man um when you say you make a movie
like a documentary a lot of people got a
plan so they're like oh I start now I
get funding do n no dude I had a camera
that I got for my wedding and I started
pointing it at people and realized they
would spill the [__] beans and so it
was at that moment I said well I should
learn to edit so I started putting it
all together and if you add up all the
time of the the first shot and all that
stuff I mean it takes years for me I'm
probably not the best there's probably
people that are way more efficient than
me but um I would say like the Lazar
film The the third film I did I mean
that took maybe n years from inception
cuz I didn't know if he would do the
film with me yeah so man I don't know
I'm doing it all the wrong ways but it's
they're coming out these are you know
movies about this topic yeah yeah UFO
people are kind of kooky some I mean
they come out of the Woodworks H H how
do you what's your [__] radar for
knowing what's truth or what's not super
tuned in I hope I mean I you know I like
um look I kind of accept I'm an equal
opportunity employer like you know
accept all information and then if I can
prove it that's solid if I can't it sits
all the way over
there when you say UFO people are Kookie
and everybody's [__] kooky there are
kooky people in every industry it's just
that this topic is so outside of our
consensus reality that you just end up
sometimes you lose your marbles by
keeping your ears open and and I notice
that marbles rolling out right and left
people get a little touched UFO disease
and I think it's because it's a exciting
topic and separating that fact from what
we want to be true that fantasy um that
can be hard existentially just you you
want things to be true when they're
not and or when you can't prove them so
I don't know the [__] meter is um
long-term vetting of individuals with
extraordinary claims based on
extraordinary beliefs longterm I mean I
piss everybody off even the people that
come to me they're like but I thought
you were going to integrate this
information I'm like well it's only been
5 years I have to get to know you make
sure that this is not a long con
okay
um very recently and and seemingly only
recently has the government acknowledged
the existence of UFOs they're real and
that is uh objectively incredible but
what I find more incredible is the fact
that when the government comes out and
says UFOs are real seemingly nobody
cares like nothing nothing changed like
like like and uh it's just like just
life goes on like I just you know now
you're obviously a lot closer to it and
so I'm sure that like a lot did change
in your view but me being just a Layman
guy like sort of I just don't it's it's
amazing to me I'm like how wait hold on
a second does nobody care yeah and and I
guess that's my first question
is is that your experience that wow like
I thought this was going to kind of make
more of a SPL spash than it did yeah uh
no I didn't think it would make more of
a splash you know uh it is this kind of
slow absorption process of what does
that even mean there's a lot to talk
about what you just said so the
government acknowledged that UFOs are
real they call them UAP um unidentified
anomalous phenomena because UFO was in
lie of flying saucer which is originally
kind of what everybody was calling him
because it was misunderstood a guy said
when he saw it Kenneth Arnold Mount
reneer this was
1948 I believe 47 I'm not good with
dates he said it it it moved like a if
you took a saucer and skipped it on
water so the media was like oh Flying
Saucer right but really the craft
weren't shaped at all like saucers the
ones that he saw so what happened is we
go into this term of UFO cuz it was
better it was unidentified flying object
okay great but now we know they're under
the water in space like this is
documented so unidentified an phenomena
is the new government term So when you
say the government acknowledged that is
correct our government has said UFOs are
real they do fly with impunity within
our restricted air space we don't know
who made them they appear we don't know
who operates them and they appear to be
able to do things that our own weapon
systems
can't our greatest fighter planes can't
the way they man the way they maneuver
and stuff so you're right they've said
UFOs are real we're no closer to
understanding what a UFO truly is who
operates them where are they from what's
the intent what they represent to
humankind so the public in general they
see that [__] on the news it's like okay
yeah we all kind of thought that cuz
we're seeing them thanks government
right but nothing's really
answered um I I think that from my persp
perspective um changing the name from
UFO to UAP
unidentified anomalist phenomena uh
makes a lot of sense because
like why would these things even
assume uh a physical form when they're
like aren't they by definition
interdimensional things I don't know see
that that's the thing now we're starting
to get to the areas of like what is is a
UFO what does this whole phenomenon
represent to humankind is it more than
just machines or craft so you just said
interdimensional let me give you a few
other theories people have so one is
like interplanetary so you're like
extraterrestrial so these are craft
coming from other solar systems from
within our galaxy or maybe Beyond Zeta
reticuli sure the famous Zeta reticuli
binary star system that Bob Lazar
brought into the Forefront through
documents he read that he doesn't even
know if it's true yes so you got that
idea extraterrestrial then you have this
one you said which is interdimensional
which is like so interesting because I
can't jokingly can't even live in this
Dimension I don't know I'm not smart
enough to understand what that means but
the way it was described in Congress
recently which I'm sure we'll talk about
is like you can take a three-dimensional
object hold it up to a light project a
two-dimensional Shadow against the wall
right kind of like Plato's Cave that
allegory whatever so when you see
something that might be of a higher
Dimension coming into existence in our
dimensional reality you're only seeing
like a representation of it it's like if
you push an orange a three-dimensional
sphere through a two-dimensional plane
on that two-dimensional plane people
will just see a growing Circle and then
a fading Circle that's what they can
perceive on that dimensional reality So
when you say it's it could be you know
extradimensional that's some of the
greatest scientists now who take this
seriously believe it could be so why
would they even present themselves if
they have this super stealth these CRA
so let's go further than that right I
mean that's the question how about this
for a
question and Los
alien H that means do you believe in
aliens in Spanish and why do I know that
because I'm learning Spanish on Babel
baby and we've got an offer for the Wild
Ride listeners and only for the Wild
Ride listeners that you will not be able
to believe we're talking about
55% off your subscription ion to Babel
and why should you want that because
number one you don't want to be a loser
who only speaks one language and number
two you can learn a second language in
as little as three weeks I mean I'm
telling you it's like playing a video
game on your phone to and you're
learning the whole time that's how I
know about the alien hanas baby so are
you going to learn a new language or
what because if you want to
55% off your subscription is a majorly
big deal and you get it if you go to
babel.com
steo that's b a
bb.com sto one more time that's 55% off
your subscription at babel.com
now let's get back to it is that like
they don't I would assume they don't
have any need to uh take a physical form
to be perceivable by us so it would like
presumably be a choice that they appear
when I would guess they don't have
totally so but let's go a little further
with that into other possibilities this
could be CU remember the true architects
of this secrecy it's not your government
it's whoever the visitors are themselves
if they're in fact visitors and not from
here originally right so whoever is
operating these craft if these are hard
physical craft they could reveal
themselves so there's an intent but we
just don't know what it is so we've got
interdimensional
extraterrestrial now there's one called
extemporal which is and sorry
extraterrestrial just by definition
means not from Earth not from this world
from outside of the world yeah from
somewhere else right so the better would
be non-terrestrial would the way that I
that I would say people say ET
extraterrestrial You' be non-terrestrial
right that'd be a good one so you got
that extradimensional then you've got
this idea of uh extemporal so the way
that a lot of the scientists that I talk
with who been working on this problem
for government and within Private
Industry say these are gravitationally
propelled we don't know much we don't
know anything about gravity we can
observe it's effects but we don't know
what it is or how to control it other
than through Mass so they say this could
be extemporal because when you shape
gravity it distorts time and space so by
definition these crafter from another
time so you've got extratemporal
extradimensional extraterrestrial or
non-terrestrial
then you have another theory which is
the idea that these have always been
here and and human beings are just kind
of tuned in now to like a breakaway
civilization or some sort of other
people that have been here before
they're from here they've been here
under the oceans whatever in Antarctica
that's another theory people like to to
put forward is that this is some sort of
breakaway civilization that been with us
a long time then you keep going you've
got these ideas that this is some sort
of simulation so what we're seeing what
they're presenting are like craft just
ahead of what we have now so we can then
have a learning process of trying to
replicate as if it's a techn terrestrial
there's another one the idea that we're
all evolving towards a technological
goal with a little bit of assistance
from others and I I love that one
because there's a lot of evidence that
UFOs are presented in their time in ways
that those people can understand them
back in the day when you say those
people you're not talking about humans
no I I I those people of that time so
it's like in the 1800s a lot of UFOs oh
okay gotcha they looked like so those
people in the 1800s they saw UFOs often
times as kind of like durables you know
but there was none at the time but that
was a technology about to come or just
budding so a lot of the UFO reports are
these like Viking floatable ships with
spotlights which we had nothing like
that at the time time but you got
reports in multiple countries within
that four or 5e period where they're
seeing that and now we've got these
craft that look Interstellar so you have
to ask yourself is the UFO phenomenon
[__] with us and are they presenting
whoever they are something that we can
relate to that's just outside of our
grasp to help Propel us forward like a
control system to educate
us or they only tend to show up in areas
where there's nuclear power and they're
watching us to make sure we don't [__]
up the Earth okay well let's get there
because the thing the thing is that
there there is an influx at all times
since we began the nuclear program since
1945 when we had the Trinity test site
explosion of the first nuclear weapon
you had an in UFOs existed before but
there's been a great interest u a kind
of increased frequency of activity
surrounding our nuclear assets including
these detonations now they haven't
stopped any of them but UFOs have come
into nuclear sites turned on and off
nuclear missiles a guy that lives close
to me is a friend of mine and he was
part of that he saw them go online
offline as a red disc came in over the
base now George knap found out through
documents that happened not only in the
US when he smuggled Russian UFO
documents back it happened in also in
Russia but it's not just like hey here's
your matches we're going to take him
from you they turned him [__] on too
so that's a kind of Flex if you ask me
okay so the UFO thing and also our
United States government has what they
call baited UFOs before so on multiple
occasions in the transit of nuclear
weapons or bringing them out places like
clockwork these things whatever they are
show up that's what I'm told and I
understand the facts to be so with that
said okay but help me with the baited
part yeah baited so like uh they were
saying to scientifically study UFOs we
have to have a repeatable process right
you can't just be like some guy saw one
some fighter pilot chased one so you're
saying that the United States government
in uh the interest of studying UFOs
effectively said troops load up the
nukes we got to transport them so that
it will uh draw the the UFOs so that we
can study them they would never tell the
troops
that put that container in the you but I
mean yeah so it is understood by me you
know take that for what what it's worth
um my understanding is at this time and
I'm pretty damn confident with it that
uh we had had opportunities to study the
phenomenon scientifically by trying to
set up the environment where UFOs would
come and that would be by baiting them
by the movement of nuclear weaponry and
uh if that's true that's pretty
astounding it does show a correlation
with our nuclear weapons I mean look
maybe this planet is really [__] cool
and we're kind of like a lower primate
species and we're [__] it up and so
they're like you know let's watch these
[__] before they blast something
right I mean I I I would guess and
totally uneducated that that all of the
uh just call them entities energies like
that there there's that we are just
fascinating oh we have to be we're
entertainment for them hell
yeah we call yeah and I I I want to get
Oliver tree to weigh in thoughts
question what's going on well a lot of
things come to mind for one in your
research since you are such a public
figure since you are so outgoing in the
public speaking about this on the news
have you had people from the government
reach out to you about these phenomenons
at all is this something that you feel
like your life is ever in danger not
because of necessarily fans but because
of some of the information that you're
bringing to light in the more mass eyes
are you posing a threat am I that's to
National Security not but do you feel
like ever that it's you feel maybe that
there is some Danger from this yeah uh
so back to what you said real quick
which is that the term people are using
is non-human intelligence because the
word alien like anything unknown to us
is alien you know so they call him
non-human intelligence we just had a
thing in Congress when that was a good
way um to your question you know have I
ever been contacted dude of course I
mean I'm obtaining releasing military
filmed footage that are of bonafide UAP
through leaks that comes to me they have
to do investigations they have to plug
leaks that's an important job when it
comes to you know proper Transit of
information uh my relationship has
always been really great in that no one
as a journalist you know has ever uh
tried to stop the the freedom of press
in that way freedom of speech and also
for public good as a journalist there a
little bit of a something called Shield
law and there's other laws that say look
if you're reporting something for public
good and you obtain you can obtain
anything just don't [__] up you know Do
no harm National Security with UFOs is a
real deal the UFO topic is considered by
our government at a level higher than
weapons of mass destruction that's not a
throwaway statement that is fact I know
that to be true so here's the deal Do no
harm I I am a patriot and but you know
I'm also a little bit of a pirate and
you've seen that by when I obtain and
release stuff but I always try to do so
with knowledge that it's been done wrong
before and it is not my intent to harm
National Security it is not and I think
anybody's ever engaged me from any
Agency on that you know they clearly see
I'm not some like crazy pirate you know
I'm just interested in this so just to
finish your qu question
directly I've always been you know I've
never been resisted I can say that I
I've been assist but the scary thing to
me is that journalists get better
briefings more footage better
understanding of some of these UFO cases
than our government uh Representatives
do so I've not been the subject where
I've been briefed often times I have
briefed on specific things which is
[__] frightening that there's so much
of a problem of the transmission of this
information where it should go cuz again
that's the qualification thing I'm just
a report a journalist that's looking at
this that there's got to be people that
have a better grasp on this within our
government but who contacts you like the
Men in Black show up no how's that [__]
work and like exchanging emails with
this sensitive information like is it
encrypted like is there protocols you
have to do oh yeah yeah as a journalist
I'm getting and obtaining information I
I just have like a couple catchalls so
when people kind of get through to a
certain point everybody knows those
catchalls exist completely encrypted
everything is is totally to the highest
degree in quality but I don't always
know what's going to come in people
could send [__] anything which is
also kind of frightening too right so
from the journalism side as a journalist
I don't want to know who gave me what I
want to corroborate it so as long as
there's enough information that comes
along with whatever sent I can
corroborate it I never want to know
specifically who gave me anything um the
other part of that is how do people
contact you so this is a weird world
that I'm living in where I'm actually
dealing with stuff where the Pentagon
doesn't have some of the footage from
their fleets that I was able to obtain
so that's an uncomfortable conversation
I'm about to go public with something
right and I did and then I gave it with
George nap as journalist we gave this
information to the Pentagon they're like
we didn't have this so that's an awkward
conversation then of course it has to be
an investigation of how that stuff got
out I get that that's the footage from
the USS was it Omaha there have been a
few instances but the USS Omaha USS
Russell 10 of our Navy warships were
swarmed by UFOs or UAP unknowns I call
them units and they seem to appear to be
trans medium go in and out of the water
with total impunity and a lot of times
these things are are fired upon I'll say
not necessarily with like metal bullets
but sometimes with electromagnetic
Weaponry on the ships electromagnetic
Weaponry that we have that we have yeah
yeah so like if you have like anti-
drone technology if you're on one of
these warships you got something called
the Ghostbuster they literally say bust
out the Ghostbuster and it's this
backpack and it can shoot down a lot of
the common drones there's higher levels
of electromagnetic Weaponry to take down
systems of objects approaching or um if
there's an incursion in your
space I know of three that were
attempted on multiple swarm incidents
but I feel like we're jumping around so
I just reel it back into one point no
sorry I just brought that up because
that's stuff that you gave to the
Pentagon that they didn't have some of
that footage absolutely they didn't have
other parts of that footage were in um
what at that time was a classified
document that was shown to educate the
the armed services about UFOs um there
was a couple images from that which I
obtained but there was other like the
radar data stuff like that all from the
same event like corroborative Visual
Evidence you got radar thermal infrared
deck footage normal camera footage all
showing the same event Series so it's
one of the most well documented now
confir confirmed UAP or UFO events in
military history because I was able to
get all of that footage and bring it
together but right back to your original
question just want to finish one thing
tie it up um look within the numerous
intelligence agencies within the US
there's a high interest in this UFO
thing it's not nefarious necessarily
it's seeking quality and actionable
information it would make sense that
people would try to gather that and go
talk to people both overtly and covertly
so I've had both I I've experienced both
where I had to find out later the true
agenda people that inserted themselves
into my lives but then overtly just hey
you're not in trouble nothing's wrong
I'm from ex agency just want to talk to
you if you call me back about this I'm
not trying to find out sources or
methods or [__] up your thing in any way
just want to get a little information if
that's okay if you ask me not only is it
okay to get information it is mandatory
and that is why I wear whoop band
because it gives me more information
about my fitness my health than any
other device known to man that's right
it is the most sophisticated Fitness
tracking device known to man it's called
whoop wh o p and if you want information
baby then get on this train because I
know everything about how I sleep how I
recover how many calories I burn all my
exercise I love it and I never have to
take it off because right here in my
pocket I always have my charger which
slides right on top and it's waterproof
baby dude it never has to come off it's
always charged and it always tells me
what I need to know and if you go to
whoop.com and use the promo code steo
then you get 10% off your membership
plus when you do that the actual abandon
the charger it's free plus 10% off your
membership get on over to whoop.com
that's wh
o.com and use the promo code steo for
10% off now let's get back to
it and all of that has happened and this
can I ask one thing this is a crazy like
this is a big question coming out
but have aliens or uaps or any
extraterrestrial
interdimensional beings reached out to
you as someone who's a spokesperson have
you had any interaction have you seen a
ship have you had any kind of personal
experience and if you don't want to
answer I understand no so I'm I'm a
total open book like I have to be you
know I feel a duty if if if if I
withhold anything you know i' I'd be
pillared for it the thing is is that I
I'm sad to report to you that I'm always
the guy with my back turned see
something cool they scream I'm inside
getting my night vision so everybody can
see the stars better there's some UFO so
I was always that guy for like ever
forever man I never saw [__] you know
and I kind of liked it that way I was
like that's pretty cool because no one's
going to believe me if I see
something luckily right luckily uh not
that long ago I had a very much more
credible to me friend uh his name is
Dave Foley he's a comic right um from
Kids in the Hall and he was was visiting
me and he started taking the piss at me
being like ah come see the UFO expert
and don't see a UFO that's pretty good
you know he's [__] with me not 45
seconds later I say Dave look the [__]
up and that was the first time in my
life I can say that I ever saw a craft
of Unknown Origin that was capable of
doing something unlike what I know is
possible with our known understanding of
physics when you say it's not possible
by our aircraft and say like we really
mean is straight up defying the laws of
physics uh it's using a uh it's applying
itself in a world of physics that we
don't we must not understand right is it
this the science hasn't caught up with
the technology yet yeah so Material
Science is our number one throttle on
any reverse engineering attempts of
these materials or craft and I can
explain that really deeply or simply if
you want but that's the number one thing
is our material science evolution from
my understanding
has not caught up to being able to
duplicate or replicate the actual uh
physical materials enough to even begin
to start and I I would assume that it
it's all operating in and by laws that
don't even apply to to our our physical
science well let's talk about that for a
second cuz it's if I can get it anybody
can get it and the thing is I've tried
to understand it and and what I'm what
we're talking about is a UFO will appear
and disappear okay great so we have
stealth technology that can make that
appear to be the case for us you know on
radar or optically we have pretty good
technology we can cloak machines we're
getting much better at it but
additionally there's other signatures
they say like let's just say thermal
like where you can mask that but also
UFOs can seem and this is the biggest
one they can appear to have zero
inertial effect so if I if I'm going 100
mph but then jolt 2,000 mph my body
becomes jelly on the back
wall these craft seem to be able to move
at 90° turns that documented about
12,000 mph so not even the machine
itself should be able to handle that
that kind of turn so obviously there's
no inertial effect so what do we know
that can cause that type of thing well
sure time travel temporal but also we
don't understand gravity if there's a
way to produce gravity like Bob Lazar
said cuz right now the only thing
produces gravity is is mass is matter
right but if we could generate gravity
you could theoretically create a
gravitational field that is inert like
you you it doesn't matter where you're
moving through time and space you're
always in a gravitational field that is
right for you that's why they think some
of these craft can move they call transm
medium from space through air without a
sonic boom they can move at speed
and into the sea without disturbance
without slowing down that's trans medium
so the idea of how do they do that with
physics some people say well the craft
skin you know it's like hydrophobic when
you go in it just slips in but really
what we're seeing is we're seeing
objects that appear to move in ways that
our physics understands we just can't
replicate gravitational fields so they
must have some way of doing it if that's
the way they're doing it and that's what
wasar saying they had that thing where
you couldn't touch it and it kept
pushing you back that's the idea behind
what that is yeah the the propulsion
system so if anybody doesn't know who
Bob Lazar is you know he's a guy that
claims that he reversed engineered or
tried to a UFO for the United States
military in 1989 he came forward through
George nap that's how you know about
Area 51 and flying saucers in general
Bob said he worked on an alien
spacecraft From Another
World it was a saucer
and the propulsion system the power and
propulsion was what he was tasked on
examining and he said when you turn on
this gravity wave amplification
machine you couldn't bring your hands
close to it so that was an aspect of
what he experienced there were other
weird things like bringing a candle up
towards it and it was like frozen
looking just stopped which he said made
no sense because electrons should be
sucked into that void shouldn't Escape
that field so he doesn't even know but
basically yeah that's Bob Lazar that is
the idea I don't know if it works that
way I'd love to
know um when you said that uh that you
know the Freedom of Information and that
you know you you created the impression
it seemed that the government has like
just a real uh you know transparent
approach to all of this no right right
so um it would s I really liked Oliver's
question about have you been in danger
and you know because it would seem that
there's potential for you to be drawing
attention to
information that the government is
actively trying to keep covered up and
that that could represent a conflict of
interest that would put you in Jeopardy
I I'm not the favorite person of some of
these intelligence agencies or some of
these groups that would have that vested
interest I'm sure locky doesn't like it
when I talk about that they have an an
actual spacecraft that they've been
reverse engineering they were given one
locky locki Martin yeah it's an
aerospace company but there are others
right is is that the one where they say
they've got the the biologics the the
corpses of other world Le what were they
just found it in me in Mexico that
little three-foot is that what you're
talking about oh that's sorry about that
yeah this was from the Congress hearing
there was this this was the sound bite
that was heard around the world where
the guy the the lady asked are you uh in
possession of any uh aircraft or you
know and the guy said well yeah we have
the aircraft and we have biologics that
was my friend David grush so he came to
me first out of concern for his sa okay
so you guys are talking about safety so
let's let's nail this one for a second
right um look I am operating within my
right as a free human and a journalist
and I'm doing my best to do no harm and
get information out I find it to be
credible um I'm sure there are people I
know that there are people and groups
that do not like the idea of disclosure
or this idea of transparency on the UAP
or UFO issue there are of course
repercussions from people like that you
know there are uh ways in which people
make can make your life quite
uncomfortable but I've I'm either immune
or ignorant or I just don't know when
I'm in trouble half the time so I think
as long as people do things legally and
lawfully and they do their best there's
always going to be push back and there's
going to be ramifications anyway for
other people there have been reprisals
that that's a big we so we should talk
about this that that I don't want to go
too weird but that that deepness of
people trying to uh harm you okay CU
that was that was said in in in Congress
was that David Gres personally there
were actions taken against him as a
intelligence officer but also other
people they even brought up like um you
know harming people so here's the deal
this is people being harmed by by people
that want to keep the secret okay within
factions of of agencies right that was
the claim that was made in Congress that
this is a true fact and we can he could
bring forward witnesses that are both
hostile and non-hostile meaning people
that want to talk people that don't want
to talk and he's got a list you just
have to have the clearance and get a
skiff so they're working on that so
here's the deal though the whole thing
is that there were reprisals against
people like David grush to come forward
he did it legally and lawfully he went
to the intelligence community's
Inspector General the Inspector General
is like the cops of the intelligence
community so it's under whistleblower
protections whistleblower protections
act it's a presidential protection act
18 or something or 19 basically he says
this is what I
know I know that we have craft that are
nonhuman origin I know that we have
biologics or Biologicals and I know
where they are and I know who's working
on them and I've interviewed 40 people
plus that have direct hands-on
experience with these materials and
these programs and he's like put that
into a whistleblow complaint
whistleblower complaint comes back they
go we find his [__] credible and Urgent
well why why did the Inspector General
find it credible and Urgent CU they did
their own under oath with polygraph
sometimes they did investigation into
the witnesses that and what he found and
it was his job by the way he was tasked
by um the U APF which is UAP task force
to look at over 2,000 black budget
programs and try to figure out or any of
these have to do with non-human
technology and he found them what what's
a black budget program so like any
program where they don't have to Define
exactly what the money is being spent on
and you can go to like the library
Congress if you're a total nerd like me
and you can find like calculate the
black budget because it'll say black
budget and you can say how much money
that we know of is being put into these
programs never tell you what's in them
they won't tell Congress anybody so the
whole thing is we need oversight there's
tons of money being spent on this and
there are UFO programs there are crash
retrievals they're of craft of Unknown
Origin to be magnanimous I'll say that
and there's biological aspects to these
crafts 100% question is does our
government have oversight from some of
the um corporations that have taken some
of these in so imagine in the 50s you're
like hey locked we got something we
can't figure out we don't know what to
do just look at it try to get derivative
Technologies you know you'll benefit
from it and locky's like oh cool and
they take that take total control and
people kind of forget about it that's
the situation we're in right now so this
guy David grush came forward because of
the of the reprisals that's why he came
to me and George knap first don't report
on it he's like I just want you to know
I'm [__] scared and so famously he
came forward to us we kept his damn
secret we didn't even break the store we
kept his secret and I'll tell you it is
true you know he was uh there's a lot of
things still going on to try to shut him
up well I the reason I asked it too is
this something I've never spoken about
but my grandfather worked for Led Martin
and there was a lot of things that he
was unable to speak about this was stuff
that he had to take to his grave so I
know there's a lot of things and you
know that could be something like what
we're talking about now it could be
Weaponry we don't really know exactly
what he did cuz he wasn't allowed to
speak about it but I also know someone
who's very tapped into a public figure
he's like someone who works closely with
the public figure who is an alien
activist spokesperson whatever you want
to call it and locked Martin people show
up to with this person that I can't get
into specifics about saying too much of
this person because it's not my business
to disclose but loed Martin people show
up a lot in this person's life and um
it's very interesting that they're such
a big part of this but it's so like
unspoken and they can't speak publicly
about these things yeah that's a shame
I'm the least paranoid person I know I
like I probably should be more paranoid
but I I it's sad to hear that so look
anything done in a classified realm
you're not supposed to talk especially
if it's a special aess program which is
above classified is like it's classified
a lot of people have top secret
clearance in this country but if it's
special access compartmentalized special
access you have to be on that program to
even know that information so when
someone works at lock if they keep and
maintain their clearances in order to
work there they can't talk about General
stuff even like is the lcky a a
private um company so there's I don't
want to just focus on them in the it's
an like an aerospace or technology a
defense department uh company so lockit
is its own individualized company but
its biggest contracts are with our
government right so like our government
itself doesn't like produce war planes
we hire out with aerospace companies to
do that so you got Ron Boeing locked all
these companies got it so a lot of these
companies have acquired materials I'll
say like over the decades right cuz they
want to figure out what here's what
they're trying to do what they're trying
to do is say we don't get what this is
but we know it can be weaponized and
we'd much rather that we weaponize this
[__] before anybody else like I don't
know say Russia China so initially the
the secrecy like the atomic program it's
so that we can have a technological
advantage in Warfare because that's the
only thing that really keeps us and
distinguishes us
is how big bombs we have and how we can
Implement them or our our Tech you know
that's it it's Warfare so I get it I get
why they were keeping the big secret for
a long time but cat's out of the [__]
bag and it's coming out of the bag even
more now and they see the writing on the
wall so what are they going to do you
can't admit to everything but you can
say like the atomic program okay we're
tinkering with the atom now we're not
going to teach you to make a bomb but
we're tinkering with the atom same thing
with UFOs f
up all right and so people like like uh
what was that group that meets up aib
atip atip and ASAP so ASAP was the
mother program and a tip was the
auxiliary program off of ASAP and these
are all the the heads of certain places
that meet up like like billionaires and
they talk about UFO [__] no no so that's
different maybe you're talking about
something else but so eight okay um who
who owned uh Skinwalker Ranch oh that
was Robert Bigalow so Robert Bigalow
would meet up with a bunch of other
people and they would discuss it's a
secret meeting or whatever but well kind
of there there's a lot in so that was
called bass so I'll break it down like
how I understand it for like 101 style
which is that you've got people bidding
on this contract to study UFOs and
Bigalow was positioned well they
retrofitted Bigalow Aerospace to be able
to have the clearance the classified you
know clearance of retaining materials
like a spacecraft so like a locked typ
totally but more nuan that it was really
this whole thing was about UFOs he
already had big low Aerospace put
Inflatables up you know attaching to the
International Space Station cool
interesting billionaire guy right but
really what they were doing was they
were like there's $22 million and so
Senator Harry Reid put this in motion
and he got this secret black budget $22
million which is like not even the cost
of one of our planes but okay and
they're like we want to do a a
technology UFO program that was the core
of it right so big say cool I will
create something called bass big
Advanced Aerospace space studies or
something like that we'll absorb that
income and we will get our facilities
ready to receive materials you know or
materials that they find like a craft
you know that was the the you know the
idea I think behind it and we'll do all
these studies get the best scientists on
this as a matter of fact I have been
doing quite a bit of research myself in
the bedroom with my lady and that
research involves consuming a blueo
tablet roughly 30 minutes before I get
into bed with her why because it's
fireworks in the sheets and I'm not
embarrassed about it hey man you know
what if I'm gonna have a good time with
Lux I might as well have a really good
time and that's what blue Cho is all
about baby and I don't know if you're
aware but the listeners of the Wild Ride
podcast can get an entire month supply
of blueo tablets absolutely for free all
you pay is five bucks for shipping if
you go to
blue.com and use the promo code steo
couldn't be more simple you take care of
your prescription right there on the
website and in moments you've got a
month supply of blue CH tablets on the
its way to your house so go to
bluechew.com and use the promo code steo
now let's get back to
it so they did that and it was under a
program in the defense intelligence
agency called oap and uh oap stands for
um aw Advanced weapon systems you know
what my brain right now it's a [__]
acronym this is the the main UFO program
that absorbed the $22 million
right then you've heard about atip atip
was reported on in the New York Times
when the public kind of found out about
this so George knap had known about it
since the beginning but he's not the New
York Times that Harry Reed called and
said please don't report this let the
New York Times break it and he's like
all right New York Times broke the story
about
atip Advanced Aerospace threat
identification program a guy named Lou
alzando Who you might have heard of who
is the guy that that led that endeavor
and that effort they weren't the
recipient of the 22 million that was M
reporting by the New York Times but a
tip they took the military cases and
they took everything that AAP when it
was ending and they took that and they
ran with it so it was very heroic to
continue this study so Lou alzando is is
a hero in my eyes that he took this and
kept going with it you know for our
military and intelligence communities so
that's the breakdown of what you learned
2017 changed the world that's when that
New York Times article came out that you
probably heard about that [__] black
budget whatever New York Times 2017 that
told the world that the government was
studying UF U secretly and before that
we were told nothing to see here move on
we ended studying UFOs in 1969 with
project boook there's no such thing but
then 2017 we find out oh yeah they're
real [__]
interested wow um let me ask you about
alien abductions we've all heard about
it I was in my you know I got sucked up
into a saucer or or whatever like like
it we know UFOs exist do we know with
equal certainty that these stories of
people being abducted by aliens are also
true I mean people that that claim that
if you hear the the Travis Walton is
very famous story Travis Walton story of
abduction he went missing for a number
of days people in the sky yeah Fire in
the Sky is a great movie you people were
going to be put in jail they would
passed poly graphs on that abduction
story so that one carries weight and if
one is true you know who am I to say
others or not I'm sure there's a lot of
[__] ones but is that basic
phenomenon real I think we're just
learning to form an alphabet here to
have a conversation about
UFOs that's down the road in my eyes is
we have to get to consensus reality on
actual reality if UFOs are real and we
accept that now it's a different era
than it was 10 years ago if we are all
there now right then we need to go into
the next phase of that which is do we
have craft from them either crashed or
gifted have we been exploiting them what
have we
learned then the hard questions will
come cuz if our government admits all
that people going to ask so can can you
just get swooped up you know can that
happen why now a lot of people that have
had what you call abductions there's
also a lot of people that just have what
you call contact right okay so there's a
famous case um aerial school and uh two
of the the women now that were children
at the time lisel and Salma or friends
of mine have talked with them
extensively about it they were kids and
this craft or craft multiple come down
drop into this aerial school well
documented 60 90 kids I don't know bunch
of kids saw it drew pictures of it John
Mack from Harvard who is head of uh
psychiatry or something or was this in
another country in Africa yeah I think
it was South Africa if I get it right
AAL school and um he went down there and
with the BBC and he interviewed all
these kids you know head of of Harvard
in this field it was a coup that he'd
take this seriously this abduction thing
so he took it seriously he's smarter
than me he was smarter than me you know
he's passed away but I'd have to imagine
that there's where there's smoke there's
fire there's got to be something to it
it's not my field I'm a like nuts and
bolets like push on the government get
some answers kind of guy but I would say
there there's got to be something to it
and and and that's mindboggling because
these kids they weren't abducted but
what happened was the craft land and
there's this being small you can imagine
like an alien looking being and its eyes
this is what every witness said and
especially my two friends they were like
I was like what's the best word for this
and they're like
mesmerized what do you mean it was like
as if all the sound went away and I was
being shown imagery in my mind of like
how we're [__] up the Earth which is
a very common thing people say when they
have these Close Encounters it's like a
movie they're playing in their head and
they said it was like transfixed and
then as soon as I broke my gaze all of
that went away it lost the control over
me was communicating telepathically you
hear that all the time now I've never
had that experience Al sometimes I think
my wife is an alien hybrid kind of spy
From Another Dimension and she does mind
control me so maybe it's like that but
whatever it is there's got to be
something to it steo I don't know man
there got to be something to it I just
think it's interesting that we've come
so far in the one area but these
situations of contact we just
like yeah well nobody owns the
UFO like it's very Democratic you know
it's like right it's like it happens to
everybody in every field and I think
once you like see one or something
you're like okay I know that shit's real
you get kind of like the bug right for
some people
um I don't know nobody owns this thing I
think that there is contact it appears
with individuals more than even
governments and if that's the case I
don't know what's going on um one
question in the context of
interdimensional and these different
ideas that maybe we can't perceive them
in this Dimension and they're in another
dimension um I've known multiple people
who have had encounters with other
species um uaps whatever you want to
refer to them as through the dream state
and I wanted to ask you about for one
also to confirm these people also were
spoken through tele telepathically so
they didn't speak but they were able to
communicate and the same message in one
of the instances was spreading the same
message of hey you guys are damaging
this entire planet and that sends a
ripple effect you know one thing gets
blown up it changes and and has a
Ricochet effect onto the next things
around but I wanted to ask you about the
dream state and if you've heard many
instances where people are reached
through the dream state and if you think
that maybe they're not physically
visible or you know maybe they're not
unveiling themselves in this Dimension
by choice or maybe they don't even have
the skills and if it's in the dream
state and if you think not to get too
many questions at once but maybe that's
a time where we're not our guards down
in the dream state maybe they're easier
to reach out to us where it's not as
we're not going to have a crazy freak
out or if if they can't even maybe reach
us in some cases in this Dimension yeah
I mean your guas is is as good as mine
unfortunately when it comes to that so I
have made myself um available to hear
everybody's account now what I can do
with that if it's actionable for me if
it's something that is you know
profoundly personal I like to hear it
because I feel like censoring
information before it comes to me so I'm
very open to hearing I've heard every
story you can imagine when it comes to
abductions when it comes to Close
Encounters when it's military personnel
when it's whistle like I've heard it all
man the the thing is or maybe I haven't
let's let's see what I hear next right
nothing will shock me but there are
things that continue to repeat amongst
people that don't know each other and
that's where it gets really kind of
Haunting to me not even in the typical
UFO Zeitgeist just little details that
continuously be are repeated and I asked
to record those conversations I can use
like you know AI word search and I can
find now you know a decade of interviews
where people are repeating things they
don't know each other and it's not
popular stuff just little things um so I
don't know if it's dream state some
people say on like DMT they can see some
aliens I didn't I mean I don't know but
you don't need to be asleep or high to
see this UFO thing I think you just need
to look up but that may be where you're
in between states that could be a place
where they can reach you I'm with you
bro I had a friend who was really big
into DMT and he had an instance where
cuz a lot of people they meet entities
it might not be referred to as aliens
but they meet other beings which I've
heard it you know there's some something
that I think is interesting we could
talk about too is just the idea of
aliens vers ghosts vers Angels you know
people are talking about entities not
even necessarily knowing what they are
but that energy that maybe is in an in
between realm I've experimented with DMT
a lot of times never experienced beings
but it's a very common thing but um this
person was was actually being he said it
was what he interpreted as an alien
actually like doing um some form of
surgery he said it tickled him though
and he didn't feel threatened or
anything he was just laughing by it but
it wasn't like he felt like he was
abducted but he felt like he was there
were someone there was working on him
that's like another conversation but
heard that a lot I think that when you
talk about being contacted in a dream
state like actual like dreaming I think
that that suggestion lends more
credibility to Dreaming than it really
deserves not that we don't dream but
just my experience of dreaming is just
all such absurd nonsense that just
doesn't you know well to answer that one
thing cuz I know someone
who his wife doesn't believe in aliens
and he does and he said that in the
instance where the time he met them and
they came to visit him after he had
disclosed a bunch of information his
wife basically was saying hey I had a
dream last night where a bunch of alien
these tall gray aliens came to the house
and he didn't perceive it as a Dream
from what I understand but she did and
so I just think that's interesting
because it's not like oh I had a dream
it's like two people had the same dream
right right have you guys ever had like
a dream or like some information that
you just knew that you had no
conventional way of knowing it and it
ended up being
true
probably
um you mean like intuition I don't know
what I mean just um just that if if if
we have received information in some way
that we didn't know how there's no
logical way that we know like no one
told you it or wrote it down it wasn't
even in the air then somehow there's
information that gets into us from
somewhere else it's like aund monkeys
Theory sure that old yeah that book I I
believe in that I don't know that I've
had had personal experience
um my my dad and my uh former stepmom
went to a uh medium like a psychic the
psychic
said um that the spirit of um my dad's
first wife which is my mother is
restless because her ashes have not been
scattered who like they and and and
literally my mom had been passed was
cremated um my sister had the this ear
with the ashes uh like literally on the
top shelf inside her closet and we
didn't you know just hadn't thought of
like of something anything to do with it
and like that that's pretty pretty
majorly specific that like the the my
mom's Spirit like uh like what needed to
be set free like you you need to do the
ashes so it's a good example right so
here here's my point now we could argue
okay if you got ashes and you know this
50/50 chance he scattered them or not
but but it's still nobody nobody she's
even created yeah I so here's the deal
whether we that is something we'll have
to choose to have to believe now that
information can kind of go into a human
consciousness without traditional
meaning we don't know yet how it works
it appears the UFO thing and information
to most people that experience that it's
a non-traditional kind of communication
so there's just so much we don't know we
we've been learning over and over for
the decades that that Consciousness does
play a role with physical matter right
that's something that we've all kind of
been accustomed to saying now but how
[__] weird is that that like there's
a state of matter can be altered by The
Observer if there's Consciousness
observing it this goes back to the
double slit experiment everybody knows
this right but have we absorbed this
like this is [__] crazy this means
that Consciousness somehow dictates the
result of physical reality so the world
is so
biocentrism what is that tell me that
this is the the the idea
that the that Consciousness like creates
the universe not like uh the other way
around the brain yeah right so well look
dude I I don't know any of these answers
but but what it is Dawns on me that we
are so what's the word like hubristic
like we're just so our hu gets in the
way so we're like well that can't be
true because and you look like a fool if
you talk about that so don't look like a
fool no one wants to look like a fool
you know look man we're [__] shooting
our ownselves in the foot with that kind
of thing everything should be on the
table as we kind of look into this new
realm right so this idea that UFOs and
like some people I remember Carl Young
wrote this book about how he thought
UFOs were a physical manifestation of
human consciousness now talk about hubis
first of all that's [__] crazy I
think he changed his mind later but
whatever this is this UFO thing there
seems to be a physical mechanical aspect
to it that really excites our military
for reverse engineering but there also
seems to be this other realm when it
comes to the UFO experience that has
more to do with human interact we're the
common denominator but Consciousness
right that's when you get into all the
weird [__] that that's associated with
UFOs so often times when someone says I
had a close encounter that's the only
part they feel comfortable telling you
but there's like weirder [__] that
happen that they don't freely admit to
anybody can say I saw UFO now you could
say that people are not going to shame
you but you start saying other stuff it
just gets a little weird I had a a lot
of of um experiences with psychosis from
when I was active in drug addiction and
I I um you know I've been clean and
sober for 15 years now and still like
abs and and at no point since I had
these experiences have I ever wavered in
that like all of the stuff that I
experienced was totally real and and by
totally real I I think to to describe
it um I arrived at the
conclusion that by by piling these
substances into my body all these
chemicals and that that that I was
effectively
eroding what I would call the barriers
between like our sort of you know 3D
compartment and you know and like and
other which is a very dangerous thing to
do uh through like uh ingestion of
substances
because by eroding the barriers you open
yourself up to
all forms of of energies low high so so
you I was welcoming in like Angels and
Demons is how I would refer to it like
super low so it's it's a dangerous kind
of a scary thing psychosis because
you're inviting in like all this
lowlevel frequency like demon [__] and
um but also it iname angels and like
there were lot like there was uh just a
lot of of fascinating experiences I had
I would classify it as demons that I
called uh trickster Spirits because they
would just entertain the [__] out of me
like just like my whole apartment would
turn into this crazy light show and like
everything was you know like like uh how
long would this go on for it like it
would like I would have episodes that
would last for like you know a number of
hours I would be in this I would be in
this like you know and different things
would happen for moments you know like
there was this uh skateboard that I had
drilled to the wall and to the
skateboard I had drilled the base of a
of an a globe like an atlet like a you
know globe that would sit on a desk so
it was protruding sideways out of the
the wall over the door and I sat there
and I watched my own face like like as
if the globe was like it was like a the
liquid Terminator my own face came
pushing through this globe and and and
it was like I I watched it and then the
the the globe itself with my face
protruding out of it just started like
it was like headbanging like you know
and I remember thinking like dude this
is so crazy like and like this this
can't be real and I'm like I'm still
seeing it like you know I had that
moment to be like this can't be real
it's still there like and then like
another beat like and it's still
happening like this is insane what do
you think that is that's a different
dimension or what I mean my take on it
was that it was just heavy demon stuff
because like when like when the chair
that I was in just erupted into flames
and I was just like wow I'm sitting in a
chair that's completely on fire I'm
totally engulfed in flames but it does
it's not hurting me it's just like wow
cool you know like I'm just sitting in
this huge fire you got your money's
worth on the drugs yeah like like
there were all like the curtains opening
and closing while these lights are going
off and like just all these different
like crazy experiences I had and and my
only response to it all was just to try
to keep shoveling more drugs into my
body to keep these things happening and
so that's like n that's scary demon [__]
you know so your idea there when you
first started talking about that that
barrier so if if the if the brain is
more of like a a like a receiver like a
rather than a there we go so like maybe
that is the ultimate thing that that
we're going to learn is that we that it
is more of a receiver and there are
certain things that can erode that
barrier that make it hard to function in
like normal reality but there are ways
in which you can permeate that and have
those experiences if they're necessary I
don't know I like this like I don't know
this reality is pretty great you know
what I mean it's like I don't know I
don't know man are there things that you
know that you can't say that if we knew
we' just blow our [__] Minds you know
whenever that question gets asked like
of course there's a lot of stuff that
that I know um that that people have
told me in confidence I'm not trying to
hold anything back would it blow your
minds like I don't know would like a
great UFO photo that the world hasn't
seen blow your mind probably not it's
like another piece like and also what is
it when someone tells you something I
tell you something so what like you know
that wasn't earned it's just some weirdo
telling you something so the what I
think is that of course I have to work
in confidence I believe a lot of the
information that I have to be true that
is not proper to put out yet until
people allow that information but it's
nothing that is going to change
anybody's Dynamic right now I I've told
you the basics our government knows that
UFOs are real that they're not from here
whatever that means we have craft we
have physical machines we've been
reverse engineering them in secret for a
long time and that secrecy continues to
this day every inch we're earning on
this battlefield of transparency is an
inch or a millon meter that people have
fought for there's nobody saying oh it's
time for a disclosure a big government
operation let's tell them some crazy UFO
stuff to distract them that's the
stupidest [__] idea in the world
that's if you really think about it
that's not what's happening I've that's
what I can tell you those big things are
true there are there's some sort of
intelligence that appears not to be
human and it's been engaging Humanity
since the beginning of recorded human
history before that we have physical
artifacts machines and even biologics
and your government has lied to you come
and clean a little bit but it's going to
continue to lie to you if you let it
slide that's what I
know the idea that there are craft and
then there's biologics seems a little
bit off to me where what what what I
would just guess to be more accurate is
that the line between the biologic and
the craft gives a pretty blurry like is
it not a theory that the craft itself is
some kind of a biology for sure man so
there's a few nuances to that so some
people say like the most common report I
get from a military person that doesn't
want to be known and they had a close
encounter is that if I hear this another
time if I got a nickel every time I
heard this I'd be rich right the CRA I
know it sounds weird I'm an engineer I
know it sounds weird I don't have any
other words to describe it the skin of
The Craft seemed intelligent like there
was an intelligence it seemed alive and
they like it kills them to say that cuz
there there's like a lot of Engineers
right right so there's the idea that the
actual machines themselves are so
integrated that it is in a sense a
biology right how we understand it but
it's still a craft that carries things
then you have the idea of biologics
being just Pilots right so you've got
craft that appear the most common UFO is
a is a silver sphere sometimes cubes
flying cubes with spherical AAS right
black cubes yeah so that's very common
um a lot of Pilots have conveyed that
publicly and privately to people that
they see cubes by the way this goes I
have articles back in the 60s flying
cubes goes back all the way as far as
UFOs this is one of the most common
shapes is a flying Cube you can see
historical documents with this the pilot
both Military and Commercial saw a
flying cube with a spherical Aura you
know that's way back so these been
around for a long ass time whoever's
Tech this is so some UFOs appear to be
piloted by an artificial intelligence so
like a drone right other UFOs seem to
carry occupants like a few right those
ents we would call biologics or
biological biologics but they could very
easily be some sort of cybernetic
organism with printed flesh that operate
as an autonomous kind of AI being yeah
also be to decoy to [__] with us they
could be like they could be like ha
these stupid shits dude if you're going
to send someone to go study an ant
you're going to make a badass
animatronic ant that kind of puts off
the right phones looks kind of like them
but they're like what's up with this
[__] he's a little weird but you know
blend in no problem so you can imagine
you know sometimes you feed like animals
in the wild with a puppet of that animal
you could see that being part of the
case so when you talk about biologics
maybe there are some sort of
non-terrestrial things in our upper
atmosphere that are biological right
maybe that's what they mean by that so
Pilots of craft cybernetic you know
drone type
things species from other places we
don't know I don't know what what is
that thing that hangs out by the USS
space station the w
or it's a you know what I'm talking
about it's like a cigar shaped Rock
that's just been there forever no that
came in uh to orbit and then took off
and that was um uuaa yeah and uh that's
Dr Harvey lobe they figured out what it
was no there's a lot of debate what that
was cuz from I'm not a scientist so I
might [__] this up but this thing came
from deep space kind of made this
roundabout around the gravitation of of
Earth however there was a it was a weird
trajectory for it and so first they were
like oh that's propulsion that thing
came from deep space came out propelled
off then some scientists say well it was
expressing gas probably you know from
the heating getting close to the Sun
that's why it changed direction of
course then they said well we can't see
that so they're like huh it must be must
have been coming from the inside core of
this piece of rock so they got all these
mental Loops they go through I don't
know go ask Harvey L at Harvard he'll
probably give you his definitive answer
on what UA mua was it was just an object
from another outside of our solar system
that came in
okay one thing I think that's
interesting based on you know talking
about these different types of crafts
and different variations it's like yeah
just like here on Earth we have so many
different R you have different races
different types and then you know people
are like oh aliens or this like we're
aliens to them essentially you know
we're just from another place when they
come to see us we're the aliens to them
what I think is interesting is thinking
about people have this misconception
maybe where they're like oh this aliens
are really good or they're actually
really bad more on the bad side is I
think what people tend to think or
they're scared cuz that we're scared of
what we don't know but it's just like
someone here it's like some people have
good intentions some people have bad
intentions obviously if we're likely to
blow up other people they're the message
of them coming to tell us hey you guys
probably like need to just protect
yourself or be like conscious of what
you're about the Chain Reaction you'll
cause but I think that's something that
when you were talking about that I feel
like there's maybe something that's
important to be spoken about is just you
know there could be pretty much endless
amounts of different races and different
types and some could have these very
negative intentions and be kind of like
using their influence to maybe be like
oh if this does blow up then it affects
our neighbors which we they don't like
or whatever their agenda is just like
humans have their agenda and they're
trying to get someone to do something
whether that's for self-gain or maybe
they want to protect it for their own
self preservation um but I think it's an
interesting concept of Angels and Demons
bro there's all all nature of different
energies man and I think it's
interesting talking about religion and
the different angels that have been seen
or circles in the sky and these
different things and kind of just the
idea that maybe this has been going on
for so long and that was our way of
perceiving it is kind of piecing it into
the way we could understand it into
words which there's not enough words to
describe most of things in the world
yeah so okay so a couple things what you
said there's three we should talk about
so one is that there's a lot of variety
of these UFOs or Craft um the the second
is you know back in the religious things
what people were seeing and also is
what's the intent good or bad those are
three things we should probably talk
about so shapes the craft I can tell you
from getting reports you know just
thousands in a month thousands and and
some people just directly just want me
to know no one else to know fine the the
shapes of these craft are so dude there
no there's no consistency like of course
you got the Spheres and you have the
cigar shape you have these kind of
fundamental shapes but when people have
like Clos encounters and they're telling
you what they saw they want want other
people to know I mean this shit's not
aerodynamic you could choose almost any
form these machines are so bizarre some
are huge the size of a football field or
larger of course some are like Delta
shaped
spheres all that Cubes but there's odd
shapes it's like as if these craft it's
like as if they come from tons of places
there's not one repeatable version of a
craft that's very common and aren't
there just like orbs just like light
sure like
angles I've got um I I I've got I think
only one more question that I really
feel that I need to ask and that
is what's up with Stonehenge are we
anywhere closer to like nailing it down
that it was aliens who built Stonehenge
because it just wasn't possible for
people to lift those rocks and I'm going
to tag on to that as part of the same
question what's up with the pyramids
yeah like so I'm going to be so
disappointing in that there's people
that know a lot more about that than I
do I've been so kind of hyperfocused and
like shaking the Trees of government
making sure people know about this stuff
um what I will say is that I I think
human beings have this incredible
adaptability Ingenuity and just because
we don't see evidence for how something
was done it doesn't mean that we we
might have lost that technology at some
point we might have had a sophisticated
Society to some degree and we lost
knowledge it takes one generation if
it's not written down to lose
information right now I do agree with
you some of that [__] is [__] wild
like we are discovering whole pyramid
complexes underneath using lar you hear
about that so under jungles will go up
in planes and shoot down like satellite
imagery use liar lasers and we're
mapping out whole temples and cities and
they're like yeah don't tell anybody cuz
they're going to go loot that [__] keep
it so it's kind of this hidden secret
that there's all these complexes stone
structures from other cultures that
don't make sense to us that [__] is
fascinating I don't know if you need
aliens to do that however there are
people that think how do you get these
stone blocks that look like they're
molded and lifted do you use sound to
lift them you can't put a razor blade
between them I would like to know but I
don't know I don't know the answers yeah
I was reading that like the the Mayan
temples the Aztec temples like everybody
thinks that the Mayes and the atics
built those like they showed up there
and they started a civilization around
around that those were already there oh
yeah yeah and and and we hear that all
the time so okay I'll outside of my
scope but I'll try to give it to you
anyway um place called puma punu and a
lot of alien UFO people like talking
about it cuz there're these megalithic
stones that this precise carving out of
the stones the stones if I understand
the story they're made of diorite
there's two things that can cut diorite
laser beams and Diamond Edge tools they
had chicken bones and copper and they
always said we didn't make these uh they
were here We inherited them and nobody
believed them because you must have made
them cuz that's our history turns out
they didn't make them and that they
don't know how these were carved like
three dimensional cutouts in diorite
stone that like absolutely precise so if
you look that up Puma punu that kind of
will spin your head a little bit which
is like what
technology other than chicken bones and
copper were used to do that and that's
where you can have your aliens cuz I
don't know right yeah that that rock in
Saudi Arabia that's just cut perfectly
in half it's just paper thin but
perfectly cut sounds like way better
examples than Stonehenge in the pyramid
no but you grew up in England right so
like Stonehenge is a mystery bro like I
you know I don't know I really don't
know much about it but the thing is
there's so much we don't know just about
our human past that we're in this new
era of like thinking hey we might be
part of a a greater
Intergalactic understanding of what it
means to be human I I mean I think that
that is
uh I don't know what to say obvious but
I think that that makes perfect sense to
me um the uh the idea I've heard it said
and I think this is credible
that um there is so much like just
irrefutable evidence of reincarnation
that it is baffling that anybody could
still like maintain skepticism on the
subject like there's just too many
examples like like you said of
information
being uh disseminated whatever like uh
and party right like you got like little
kids you know two years old like oh yeah
you know like um my my when I was the
president of this company or something
the boy that was born before is a great
documentary on one of these cases right
yeah that and there's there are endless
examples of of like of children knowing
things recog izing people like having
information that they just could not
possibly have that it's like okay let's
just uh you know let's just lock this in
let's just lock this in and say re
reincarnation is real I think that the
same kind of
philosophy it's got to apply
to to to this uh how to chicken bones
and copper like that's that that to me
sounds like a very credible uh credible
example of like you
know the equivalent of a little kid
knowing precisely information about a a
past life where it's like okay this kid
is reincar the reincarnated that person
like you got chicken bones and copper
and they're cutting things that only
lasers and diamonds can cut so the thing
was that they didn't cut it though
that's the thing like they was there
before them so the idea so you're
talking about right so so so the
existence of something that could not
exist right so so you're talking about
and it fascinates me continuity of
Consciousness this idea that maybe this
idea of reincarnation has been well
studied there's a university has one of
the longest studies on this they studied
children they're trying to see like what
they would say about their past that
they'd go resolve those cases and find
out and weird things when I've read
about it which is like the kids would
have like birth marks associated with
the injuries they had in that so it's so
funny it kind of comes full circle in
that this idea of Life what happens when
you die life after death and this in
interest in like the UFO topic that's
like that guy Bigalow was really
interested in it the guy that owns
Skinwalker Ranch so he's actually
started something called bicks which is
like a it's a whole study on the
continuity of Consciousness now because
these big questions they excite people
you know and if you you know if you're a
billionaire and you can just kind of
study the cool [__] um that's what
people do but I don't know I I am so
fascinated with this life I'm so
fascinated with the unanswered questions
I I disdain I have disdain for when we
think we can just put something in a box
and say oh we figured it out without
actually looking at it that that's how I
start in the UFO thing was I was very um
it was very dismissive people were very
dismissive scientists were I was like
what the [__] you should be salivating
over the idea yeah of of what you can
study so I don't know man this idea of
um continuity of Consciousness that'd be
cool I think that the whole question of
what happens like after you die it like
to me is so silly and I love that you
said it that that our um our brains are
receivers not transmitters I've had this
conversation with a number of people um
you know like in general and on this
podcast specifically but the idea that
our brain generates consciousness that
it's a transmitter that it that uh
Consciousness originates and and comes
from the brain would would s like to
believe that would be to believe that
when the brain dies that that that
there's nothing left but if you just
shift your perspective on that and say
okay maybe the brain is not a generator
of Consciousness but rather it is a
receiver of Consciousness now we're
looking at the brain as like a radio
that's picking up a signal and this is a
metaphor and analogy that anybody can
can grab on to that if you take a radio
and smash it with obliterate it with a
sledgehammer you've killed the radio but
you've done absolutely nothing
whatsoever to affect the signal that
that radio was picking up right and
right there in that simple analogy that
simple metaphor like you
completely grasp the idea that death
isn't real you know like the idea of a
soul and you know like uh it just seems
it seems silly to me that uh people are
so hung up on the idea that oh is there
life after you die it's like dude come
on bro I I do want in what you're how
you're describing Imagining the Smashing
of the radio I do wonder if we think
about it this way what if that you know
Consciousness is the medium through
through which you both your brain
receives information but also like if
you have a microphone it absolutely
influences the physical world we see
that in what we're talking about before
the quantum physics and the idea so if
that is true maybe we're both maybe that
the brain is both a receiver and a
transmitter but the space in which that
occurs that is consciousness right that
is right that is the idea maybe and when
you get Collective Consciousness
everybody put together then now we're
all in agreement that we're seeing the
same thing now you've got like IR like
immutable laws of science which apply in
every situation because the collective
Consciousness has uh generated this uh
you know
this uh illusion of reality you know and
that's why when you what like when you
ask the question like what are the odds
that a universe so expansive it goes on
and on forever and ever and ever yet
somehow there's only this like
immeasurably like minuscule like tiny
little little speck in it that that's
able to uh like Foster life like what
are the odds that just only life can
exist and it's one thing in the middle
of this expansive universe that goes on
and on forever like that doesn't seem
probable and then if you flip that on
its head look at it the other way change
your perspective but what are the is it
not more likely that our
Consciousness is a as Tiny as that
little dot able to project this yeah you
know like uh that that the that the
universe is constructed by Consciousness
yeah yeah there it's a great yeah I
don't it's like uh worse than the
chicken or the egg I I don't know if
we'll ever really be able to figure that
out but it's it's a look man the expanse
of the universe like how big the
unimaginably big they say it's probab
statistically improbable that we're the
only life but I agreed with what you
said earlier we must be [__]
fascinating at this stage of our
development the toys we got the stupid
things we do I'd watch I do watch that
show right I mean it's awesome welcome
to planet Earth the greatest show in the
solar system I'm sure that much we're
like the Kardashians of the universe
that's that's epic you know who's
getting the royalties though for who's
watching that who's watching this man
yeah who knows so so uh you have a
YouTube channel weaponized yes yeah it's
just my personal YouTube channel at
Jeremy Corbell but we have a show George
nap and I have a show together so George
knp is a gangster old school
investigative journalist about this UFO
topic he was on it before anybody you
know he brought Bob Lazar forward so
luckily I get to kind of sit with him
and have our private conversations and
investigations and sometimes we guess
public and it's really [__] fun so
that is the YouTube Channel um then you
can watch the show weaponized on podcast
and stuff you can have Tom D long on
Tom's a good friend of of George's and
uh and also M I've known him for a while
um sure I mean I I I don't know we don't
even know what we're doing next week to
be honest with you you so it's like it's
just a matter of like finding the time
for everybody but um who is next I don't
know but George and I will be there I
love it dude love it I love it it's such
fascinating stuff and um I I I love your
uh just your your uh intoxicating
curiosity it's uh you know you like
contagious okay I love it you're you're
clearly just so jazzed on uh on being
alive and and and just the Wonder and
the Curiosity of the universe and uh
it's inspiring man thanks but I
appreciate that I you know the thing is
is um I think when you in life I get
excited about coffee you know I get
excited about you know the little things
it's like this is just happens to be a
big question and I feel like it's
Uncharted Territory and when in our
lives can we really be like topographers
we're creating a map of something
there's so much we know but it's the
things we don't that really excite me so
I think that's what draws me it's the
UFOs is like it's a thing but it's
really the fact that not only do we not
know but we're like resisting studying
it so that's why I'm most excited about
it you right yeah I I I love love it man
I hope that uh you don't step on any
toes and have anybody coming after you
you know Oliver's obviously worried
about your safety I'm worried about you
worried care no I'm good man I'm
directed and protected and too stupid to
know when I'm in danger I found out so
we're good yeah I think I I think we
have that in common
man pretty much yeah but yeah hey man
thank you so much brother yeah for sure
yeah that was awesome all right bro
thank you than you very much we always
ask people I don't think there's
anything that we could possibly uh be
concerned about we always say to guests
after we're done like there's anything
that you're apprciate that I'm good
brother oh good yeah yeah um yeah that
that was I had to pee so bad that whole
time and but I was I was just fascinated
yeah there you have it baby do you feel
enlightened or do you feel scared well
I'll tell you how I feel I feel full of
gratitude to be talking to anybody at
the end of this episode and I know that
there's a bunch of you and I love you I
love you so much and um what can I share
with you in this room um before we did
these ad reads we mapped out the rest of
the year and it's gonna be [__] crazy
just putting that out there it's gonna
be [__] crazy the end of this year
this year's going to end with a
bang some
bazas